back here in new york the u.n security
council will meet today to talk about
the crisis in ukraine as thousands of
ukrainian citizens have joined local
defense units and are now participating
in drills in preparation for a possible
russian invasion holly williams is in
ukraine where she met some of these
citizen soldiers
on any given saturday
on the outskirts of ukraine's capital
these volunteers do a quick warm-up
before they're put through their drills
training to fight in case there's a
russian attack
i know russian very well alexi vasil
chenko works in marketing and told us he
served in the soviet army before ukraine
gained its independence from moscow just
over 30 years ago
if you want a peace you should be
prepared to war many here are urban
professionals there are military
veterans and new recruits many armed
only with these stand-in plywood rifles
ukrainians are determined to defend
their homeland but they're massively
outgunned and outnumbered by their
colossal
neighbor russia has been moving fighter
jets and missile systems into belarus on
ukraine's northern border russia says
for military exercises
[Applause]
moscow maintains it has no plans to
invade but that doesn't explain the
roughly 100 000 russian troops on
ukraine's border
back in the forest they're keeping up
their fitness
and practicing for urban warfare
everywhere here is our land so we have
to defend it
alexei elusian is a criminal lawyer
it makes me angry but it's not like ah
what am i gonna do it makes me angry
like to prepare myself you know
the u.s says a russian invasion of
ukraine could be horrific but there's
still time for russia's president
vladimir putin to change course for cbs
morning's holly williams in eastern
ukraine